maud a acheté la maison tes lèvres comme
elle est prudente elle a souscrit une
assurance tous risques
un jour la digue située à quelques
kilomètres de chez elle
c'est le lot n'atteint pas sa maison
mais les égouts débordent blanc son
groupe sous sol mode et tranquille à une
assurance tous risques
mais ces deux mots les promesses ne
disent pas tout le contrat qui vient
avec est plus nuancé
les dégâts causés par l'eau sont
couverts lors d'une rupture sidel de
conduite par exemple ou si le bain
déborde mais si les dommages résulte
d'une infiltration le refoulement
d'égout ou du débordement d'un cours
d'eau c'est une autre affaire et ce
n'est qu'au recouvert pour se protéger
contre les débordements et les
inondations
il faut ajouter un avenant qu'ils font
payer ce que monde n'a pas le fin mot de
l'histoire ne vous prie pas aveuglément
au monde tous risques
vous pourriez vous retrouver avec l eau